it's mom all yeah it's just us you and
us who you were in the bar with how he
names us a lost where did you see the
lady wasn't the one lady the female
jogger it was severely beaten and raped
every black male who's in the park last
night
is a suspect I need all of them what's
going on with my son your son was
involved in the rape in Central Park
they saw you rape the lady and see a
lady or hit anyone I don't see any lady
Kevin I want to see my son right now
right now
whatever they said I did
nothing these boys state matches the
central facts of the crime all we need
is for one to tie this whole thing
together these tapes are not as clean as
the state would have you believe there
is not one shred of evidence the frenzy
of these teenagers ripping offerings
innocent of these cries guilty
looks like this what other way they ever
do us these trainers parents footsteps
can you come closer closer
thank me coming from you all
they said if I went along with it dad
were gone and that's all I wanted the
police would do anything on us they
would lock us up it will kill
this is my life
I don't think we should admit to
something that we didn't do okay you
keep fighting
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you